this is where the internet comes ashore
beaut in Cornwall the seaside town is
one of the centers for spying in the
digital age a crucial staging post in
the infrastructure of the internet
either it's the frontline for fighting
terrorism or for the mass surveillance
of citizens in violation of their basic
rights today Parliament's Intelligence
and Security Committee or the ISC will
give its verdict with the publication of
a long-awaited report into the Edward
Snowden revelations directly below me is
an underseas cable to carrie's internet
traffic from the UK to the US so every
time you make a google search you like a
facebook photo or you send an email that
travels under the seat four thousand
miles to America 4,000 miles back in
less than a second but it doesn't return
to your computer untampered with some of
that data is siphoned off this is where
it goes a little way down the coast is
the GCHQ listening station at bude since
2011 according to documents leaked by
Snowden it has been hoovering up data
for more than 200 underseas cables as
part of a program called tempura that
includes new cases in personal emails
and the internet browsing history
where's not all huge satellites and
tapping underseas cables take this SIM
card it's made by belgium company called
Gemalto they make two billion SIM cards
here chances are your phone has one in
it they believe they were hacked by
either GCHQ or the NSA that means they
could have had access to your most
private communications the calls you
make the text messages you send if you
or I were to hack into Gemalto and do
the same sort of thing well we'd
probably be going to jail for a very
long time according to an internal
report disclosed by Snowden GCHQ has
increased its ability to monitor
personal data by seven thousand percent
since 2008 back in November 2013 spy
Chiefs were called in to explain their
agency's work to the ISC the
Intelligence and Security Committee with
its new pars investigates the operations
and
scrutinizes the capabilities of the
intelligence agencies there are strict
criteria in the law which provides
safeguards to protect privacy to the
maximum extent possible so since I I
definitely like to admit the privacy
security balance because I think it's a
false choice I think our job is to
provide intelligence around security
which enable security in a way which
safeguards privacy to the maximum extent
possible spies are of course going to
spy it's their job but it's the ioc's
job to check their power and the only
real challenges to GCHQ have come not
from the ISC but from NGOs and human
rights organizations bringing their own
legal cases the country's most secretive
court the investigatory powers tribunal
recently ruled that this bulk
intelligence gathering was fully lawful
but it also said that prior to December
2014 GCHQ intelligence sharing with the
NSA under that agency's prism and
upstream mass surveillance programs had
breached fundamental human rights what
we need is proper beefy toothy in
oversight from a body which unlike the
ISC isn't linked into the executive and
which has proper investigative powers
and that's just not what we've got at
the moment if the ISC report is a
whitewash that's only going to intensify
the debate on our private data what
happens to it as it makes its way around
the world Tom cheshire Sky News